how do you feel how you've been Iron Man
for a while as you probably know cuz
you're you how does it feel being here
comic-con Ironman anything it just it
just keeps getting better and I'm so
excited that that we're all here this is
the longest bench of talent I've ever
been a part of and and we got a real
nice movie coming up for you guys next
year I mean in terms of in terms of all
the films you've done this is probably
the first time that you're actually I
mean you're genuinely part of this
family of people now that's ongoing yeah
and I become a little less significant
every time which is just fine because
they're all so damn good you're probably
right hey Jeremy how's it going good
[Applause]
yeah I'm wearing pants so now that
you've been now that you've done this a
couple of times does this seem like old
hat to you or is it comfortable that
still seem exciting and new well it's
always thrilling then it's always like a
in a new look it's a Friday next week
and then it's gonna be just exciting
next Friday it's always a brand new
amazing thing glad to be here very
honoured every day that every day do you
go to work you go this is strange that I
get paid to do this every day what I'm
doing now no not this this is you're not
getting paid for this I mean oh no this
is free Jeremy was promised compensation
we're gonna have to discuss this we're
gonna do a Kickstarter we're gonna
kickstart Jeremy's panel but I mean just
you know getting over the super people
and and and essentially being a
superhero for a job I mean it was this
would you envision when you're like I
want to be an actor like does this
anywhere near what you thought no oh no
no it's a bit of wonderful blessing
meeting this guy over here he's the one
convinced me and washed my car in a song
and said that you gotta be Hawkeye
oh yeah Michael Bay style but to do that
you washed my car and a thong he's
amazing that photos on Instagram that
[ __ ] but no is easy to to want to join
wasn't very hard convincing me to do it
and never envisioned it but I'm glad to
be a part of this amazing group of
humans sitting at this table yeah
Mark Ruffalo we did the panel for when
the Avengers when the Avengers was first
announced there really wasn't a whole
lot of footage and we were in York
comic-con and and you were on the panel
and at the time you're like I don't
really understand all this comic-con
stuff and what this is and you did it
and since then it completely blew up did
this exceed your expectations
slightly by a huge margin and they don't
treat me like this at home that's for
sure when I walk to the door it's it's
pretty
it's that that's really nice thank you
oh crap just say it mark that's when it
gets bad you have to keep his pulse down
two people should shout Hulk things at
you just out in public that people don't
even know who I am other than Hulk I
walk down the street and I just say go
walk oh you just go the names banner and
then a people walking it's actually
banner Chris hey how's it going man you
[Applause]
know you are an exceptionally good shape
[Applause]
that are the size of my torso what his
what his Thor meant to you all this time
I mean has these guys said this is for
me the same thing one of the best
experiences I've had on a set office set
to work with this group of people and to
bring this character to life and be part
of this madness is his piston and honor
Tosi is there anything that you haven't
done as Thor yet that you feel like oh I
just really want to do this thing as
though I really want the floor to do
this turn to him turned him into a woman
I don't speak too early and jinx it but
I think it could be my Oscar it's gonna
be a big transformation but I'm willing
to take it all we could do it pause
while everyone stops to picture you in a
dress and then has a lot of feelings and
I gotta tell you now he's got that
pretty girl hair I think he'd be fine I
got a couple of nice wigs
cobie smulders also movie fan yeah we're
just talking a little about stage like
what a whirlwind is it make you
basically swoop in and do this and
people scream and cheer and then and
then you leave do you get to enjoy the
comic-con at all yeah I'm not that you
know going on the floor or anything but
it was my first time doing a signing
with these guys which is pretty
incredible to get to meet people and
sign pictures and kind of connect for a
second so excellent and did you you you
I think we talked you didn't expect like
this would just keep going on and on for
Maria right no I hoped I hoped yeah but
when when Joss sort of Joss is the one
who kind of brought me into this world
and and I'm sorry he can't be here I'm
sure he wishes he could be but yeah he
kind of brought me into this world and
it's just been fun just keep keep going
on the TV and I'm just I'm so grateful
so excellent
[Applause]
Sam Jackson does it feel
yeah I can't hear the question please
does it feel good to put the eyepatch
back on cuz I feel like last time we
talked about it you're like I bump into
stuff a lot because of my depth
perception with the eye patch on how
smart to figure it out my head to the
right all works out fine them I've got
that down pat gonna have that down pat
now Kevin you can cancel the insurance
[Laughter]
so how do you feel like how does how do
you how do you think Nick Fury would
react to this type of reception um you
know Comic Con is is phenomenal it's
it's it's totally amazing it's like
every year I've been coming here since
like Episode one Star Wars so seems like
every year I come here and it validates
the fact that I belong and I get all
this energy and love from everybody that
makes me feel like going out and making
movies for the rest of you we make we we
make movies because we want to entertain
you guys and I make movies because I
want to see myself in them is the
perfect combination for me all this love
and it just energizes me and I can't
wait to come back next year with the
next movie excellent now let's go over
to Chris Evans who's decided
I don't like this going down the line
thing this is intimidating it's very
assembly line right the whole time
you're like what am I gonna say what's
my aunts are gonna be what's gonna be I
I heard a story that I wanted to confirm
from you and I don't know if it's true
but I heard that when you and Hemsworth
four started working together that you
you guys were like comparing like muscle
rip edge and you're like but how do you
get this little piece right here Lots
there's no comparison I mean come on
it's very difficult to stand next to him
II literally he is four it's not it's
not just a costume he is an enormous
it's it's it's it's it's difficult to
try and keep up
how do you keep up like how long how
long is your workout your magic CGI
congratulations on the success of Winter
Soldier yes do you feel like do you feel
like at this point that Steve the cap is
like fitting does he feel more
acclimated to this world yet or does he
still feel a little isolated well no I
think he's getting there I think we're
past you know he's not just you know
amazed at cell phones and the Internet's
I mean I think he's up to speed but I
think he's still looking for a place to
belong you know he's he's for so long
been a servant you know he fits in as a
soldier you know he's used to kind of
this chain of command and since shield
kind of fell apart in the last movie
it's it's more about this group of
people depending upon each other without
kind of a clear leader and I think he's
searching for you know home yeah I'd
like to welcome Aaron taylor-johnson
Quicksilver who we just get a peek of a
little bit how is it felt coming into
this established world with all these
people been working together as kind of
as the new guy yeah pretty overwhelming
and surreal and you know as flats it to
you know that Joss and the Marvel guys
approached me for this and you know
don't hesitate you know it's a huge you
know it's incredible to be a part of
this gang and great actors and you know
was it was
anything about doing a superhero film
that you never envisioned before like
what what's different about it than
other stuff that you've done avenges
yeah I think you know I mean it's just
the the characters you have such a
dynamic between you know the group and I
think you know what Joss did with the
first one was seem like a a mission
completely impossible to do but everyone
had their moment and stood out and you
know what's beautiful is you get these
kind of characters in the same room and
they bounce off of each other you know
there's banter and humor and it's and
and he has that tone where it can be
have a journey and be emotional and sad
at moments and and and you know
light-hearted and action-packed you know
it's you know III thoroughly enjoy all
of Marvel movies and was so excited to
be a part of this one I'm very excited
to see Paul Bettany make the jump from
Jarvis from a disembodied voice to a man
on screen I used to turn up to a dark
room for 45 minutes and get a bag of
cash and now I have to work so how's
that been it has that experience been
for you everybody's been incredibly
welcoming and it's been you know it's
the most X it's exciting for me it's
been the most exciting thing that's ever
happened to my children and now all the
neighborhood kids are gonna be turning
up your house and asking you to do the
voice and I've had to keep this secret
for a year and a half and and so of my
kids which is pretty impressive you know
it's cool that they just didn't breathe
word out of it that you know of that I
know of is early welcome James Spader
[Applause]
whoa is it have you been a comic-con
before is this your first comic-con I
came last year to comic-con for a TV
show I do called the blacklist yeah and
you know I I just want to say something
to all of you guys is I have I've always
thought my whole life that life could
never get weird or crazy enough for me I
got to tell you something this place may
be the weirdest craziest place I've ever
been
[Applause]
[Laughter]
it's cuz of all of you guys and so I
thank you for that because it is really
fantastically crazy here nuts
you should Pat yourselves on the back
everyone that you are now a part of
James Spader's weird fever dreams so
what what can you take what can you say
about Ultron and what your approach to
the role and kind of what you want to
bring to it I play an eight-foot robot
in this movie and it was it was I've
always played humans up until now it was
shooting this film was as startling and
surprising and challenging and exciting
as coming here truthfully for the first
time it was doing this film was
everything everything was so entirely
new the process in making it playing
this character all of the people the
world that I was entering even the world
that these movies inhabit not just in
terms of story in place and people and
so on but
just the part of the movie business that
these movies inhabit is entirely new to
me and it was just unimaginably exciting
I mean just on a magically exciting also
welcome Elizabeth Olsen
[Applause]
it's like quite a list of people to
follow right now it is and you're the
last one no it's good and so you're the
other you're the other new character on
the block so to speak in terms of
Scarlet Witch and and so what is your
experience been like coming into the
group and being another the new gal it's
been awesome I was first really
intimidated by all of the people I was
going to potentially work with and then
everyone was incredibly welcoming and
it's just been so much fun and it's it's
fun to bring a new element to the game
there's now magic there's you know
mutant mutated people
what are you even get that what everyone
who had four mutants a bad word yeah I
know I know I know but anyway it yeah I
think it ends up and like adding
something kind of epic to the fights
that there's just a new element it's
just not just you know awesome punching
and I don't know like now we get to do
something different and I think it it
brings up with what we're marbles going
with their other films as well and
having all day it's just like the
beginning it kind of feels like just the
beginning when you're preparing a
character that does all of the things
that she does is it any different than
repairing just if you're just playing a
regular non witch yes I practice daily
just like staring at a pencil and trying
to get it ours it's not working though
it's what is it working at you should
steer do it I'm nailing it
she actually cast a spell on me two
weeks ago and I'm just hopefully before
this is all done she'll relieve me of it
it burns
that could mean anything that could mean
anything
you guys we can't be getting giddy this
early no I know I'm not supposed to
swear but holy [ __ ] that is insane
I don't even know I mean okay you saw
that are you saw Ultron I don't know how
you top Ultron bad guy wise you know the
great thing about Marvel is they've
always got the next thing up their
sleeve so uh well you know we've got
Thanos
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
where's my rose
[Applause]
we love you guys so much we're so
excited thanks for coming we're gonna
keep trying to do our best for you hey
gentlemen
The Avengers age of Ultron out in May of
2015 please continue to stand your feet
a huge round of applause for the entire
cast the age of Ultron and Fatah
[Applause]
you